il n'avait pas encore 20 ans il
connaissait pas ses parents on
l'appelait totaux la rippe est à la
villette
peut il était un peu sans façon mais
c'était un joli garçon c'était le plus
beau c'est
chouette à la vilaine
ce n'était pas ce qu'il ya de mieux me
il avait pas les beaux habits il se
rattrapait sur sa casquette à la ville
il avait deux petits jeux de sourire il
avait de petits favoris surmonté du fil
rouge laqué à la villette
il avait un dossier qu avait une grosse
qu'elle de terriers
on peut croiser une fête à la vilaine
de son métier faisait rien
bonjour il balade et son chien la nuit
compter ma galère à la ville
il m'est même autant que je l'aimais ne
nous saurions quittez jamais
si la police était pas fait la ville
les premiers aux yeux bruns on peut pas
conserver à ils finissent tous à la
requête à la villette
la dernière fois
que je l' ai vu il avait le torse à
moitié nue
et le coup pris
dans la lunette
à la roquette